son vientos de fuerza extrema localizan
y destruyen todo a su paso los tornados
se cobran la vida de entre 3 y 400
personas cada año la mitad de ellas en
eeuu un fenómeno que se forma en las
tormentas cuando el aire cálido y húmedo
choca con el aire frío y seco creando
vientos de hasta 500 kilómetros por hora
en su caso a diferencia de otras
catástrofes naturales como los huracanes
es difícil saber qué impacto ha tenido
el cambio climático en su historia
reciente
de momento no hay cifras concretos para
comprobar si ha habido más o por el
contrario menos tornados
a pesar de la falta de datos concretos
lo cierto es que cada vez se los filma
más los cazadores de tornados están
equipados para detectarlos y seguirlos
sin importar el peligro que esto implica
y sus espectaculares imágenes a menudo
se hacen virales en las redes sociales
en eeuu los cazadores de tornados suelen
recurrir a medidas extravagantes el
devastador fenómeno sigue fascinando con
escenas que para muchos simbolizan el
poder abrumador de la naturaleza